aquí tenemos algunos datos que podemos
dibujar en un diagrama de dispersión que
se ve así y la pregunta aquí es dado que
ya hemos hablado mucho sobre rectas de
regresión la pregunta es si podemos
ajustar una recta de regresión aquí si
lo intentamos podemos dibujar una recta
así o quizá una recta que se vea si las
estoy dibujando tratando de adivinar el
punto es que podemos ingresar estos
datos en una computadora y tratar de
encontrar un modelo de regresión lineal
que minimice la suma de los cuadrados de
las distancias de los puntos a la recta
pero pueden ver que es difícil de hacer
quizá algunos de ustedes vean estos
datos y piensen que corresponden a una
exponencial por lo que quizá una
exponencial se ajuste mejor a esta forma
no se equivocan pero hay otras formas de
aplicar las herramientas que ya
conocemos de la regresión lineal a este
conjunto de datos la forma de hacerlo es
que en lugar de graficar los datos en x
contra los datos en que debemos pensar
en x contra el logaritmo de g aquí
tenemos el mismo conjunto de datos vemos
que tenemos los mismos valores para x
pero
para los valores de ya tenemos el
logaritmo base de 10 de los valores de
10 elevado a qué potencia es igual a
2.300 7.23 pues 10 elevado a la potencia
3.36 es la respuesta se hizo esto para
todos los datos de la tabla en una hoja
de cálculo si gráfica mos esto va a
ocurrir algo genial al graficar x contra
el logaritmo de james tenemos algo que
parece ser lineal pero debemos tener en
mente que la relación real de x contra y
no es lineal sino un tipo de relación
exponencial lo valioso de esta
transformación en los datos que por
cierto hay varias formas de
transformarlos en este caso cuando
transformamos los datos usando el
logaritmo de y podemos usar las
herramientas que ya conocemos de
regresión lineal ya que podemos ajustar
bastante bien una recta de regresión
lineal a este conjunto de datos una
recta como ésta coincide bastante bien
con esta gráfica la razón por la que nos
interesa hacer esto en lugar de tratar
de ajustar una exponencial es porque ya
tenemos muchas herramientas para rectas
de regresión lineal como pruebas de
hipótesis
entes e intervalos de confianza por lo
que tiene mucho sentido hacer esto
otra cosa genial es que cuando ajustamos
una recta de regresión lineal de esta
forma no es difícil hacer lo opuesto
matemáticamente para regresar a la
gráfica exponencial original en resumen
podemos usar las herramientas que ya
conocemos sobre regresión lineal y
usarlas aún cuando la relación
subyacente entre x y james no es lineal
la manera de hacerlo es transformar los
datos aquí calculamos el logaritmo de
las 10 lo que nos ayudó a haber una
relación lineal entre el lugar it mode y
contra x nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo